okay so now it's on good morning
everyone and thank you all for coming my
name is Marc seaman and if you want to
know more about me there's information
there unblock the plate at DK and also
i'm on twitter at plur so you can follow
me there and what i'm going to do today
is i'm going to try to answer a few
frequently asked questions and the talk
is going to fall in three parts so in
the first part I'm gonna look at one
frequently asked question and try to
talk about why does it make sense to ask
that question but then I'm not gonna
answer the question yet because we need
some more we need some more knowledge
before we can you know probably answer
that question so that's part one of the
talk just establishing what's the
question now in part two of the talk I'm
going to post another frequently asked
question and start to discuss you know
why why are people are asking that
question and what can you do about it
and then then I'll try to answer that
question and then in part 3 we're going
to go back to the original question from
part one and try to define understand
now we have enough knowledge from part
two so that we can start to address the
question from part one and that's going
to be part three so the first frequently
asked question that we will look at here
is how do I combine dependency injection
with a sink and the weight without leaky
abstractions so that's that's the hard
part if you if you don't add that
qualifier it's not that hard and we'll
see in a little example of that
so we'll basically what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna just walk through a
lot of code and just show you what it
means when we actually write code and
the rubber meets the road and I'm gonna
need an excel scenario for that I have
one that I keep coming back to over and
over again and rewrite that you know
lots of times and that's the sane area
of having to develop an online
restaurant reservation system you know
it's one of those things where you want
to make a restaurant reservation so you
find a forum on a website or something
like that and you fill in the details
about the reservation you'd like to make
you press the submit button and the UI
creates a little JSON document that it
posts to an HTTP endpoint somewhere and
the code that we're going to look at is
this
Versailles code that receives that JSON
document and makes decisions about you
know how to proceed so the first thing
we're going to look at is actually not
the boundary where we received the JSON
document but the unicode domain logic or
the business logic if we will so I'm
gonna start just talking a little bit
about the method signature itself here
we have a method called try accept and I
will fill it out with some code but I
just want to spend one minute talking
about the method signature itself so you
can tell that it it receives a
reservation object and that's just a DTO
that contains the data from that JSON
document so that is the name the email
address the date and the quantities it's
just those four pieces of information
and then you'll notice that it returns
an honorable int
what's that int well it's a reservation
ID if you have a reservation ID you have
a reservation and you can use that
reservation ID to further manipulate the
reservation you can change the
reservation you can cancel the
reservation and you can do things for
the reservation in general now if you
don't have a reservation ID that means
you don't have a reservation so if you
get an all back that means unfortunately
we could we couldn't accept your
reservation and that might be reasons
for that we'll look it into that next
now if you doing dependency injection
you might have injected dependencies
into the class where try accepts it's on
so we might for example have injected a
repository and just you know make that
available via a read-only property like
this so you know normally this would
arrive via constructor so in constructor
injection but since this is 2019 I
assume that people know how constructor
injection works so I'm just decided to
save a little space and not actually
show the constructor
but this arrives via the constructor and
is now available as a read-only property
so since we have a repository we can now
go and query it so we can say give me
all the reservations for that particular
date once we have those we can create or
calculate the sum of all the quantities
of those reservations that gives us a
number of reserved seats and if we also
know the capacity of the restaurant we
can now make a decision so we can say if
that capacity is too small compared to
the number of reserved seats we already
have and the new you know requested
quantity then unfortunately
we sold out or we were so close to sold
out that we can't accept the reservation
and that's the reason why we might
decide to return null so we have to
reject that request otherwise we can
move on and you know finally we can call
repository dot create and that creates
or you know persists the reservation in
the repository and the create method
returns an INT and the interest gets
converted into an honorable end so this
point there's no easing in a way to
stuff going on I'm just trying to
establish you know what what didn't you
look like just without async and await
and then we can see how II think in a
weight you know tends to add leaky
abstractions as we go along but let's
just complete the example here so um if
you're doing a little bit of domain
modeling maybe you say well okay so that
try accept things looks like it's a
concept so maybe we can amplify that by
you know defining an interface called a
Maitre D' so Maitre D' is the basically
just friends it meets the headwaiter
that's typically the role in a
restaurant that makes decisions on
whether or not to accept the reservation
so a little bit of domain driven design
here we adopting the ubiquitous language
of the domain that we're working in so
if we have a Maitre D' interface like
this we can use a dependency injection
again so we have a post method on a
reservations controller sitting
somewhere and this is the method that's
actually gonna receive the JSON document
you know already encode in a reservation
detail and then it's going to return
some sort of action results and exactly
what that actually resolved is it's not
really important and we don't need to
need to know the details of that but
that will be some sort of HTTP response
so if we have an objected Maitre D' what
we can do is we could basically delegate
most of the work to the maitre d we can
call try except we get an honorable ID
back the only thing we need to figure
out now is to say well what sort of HTTP
response should we return based on
whether or not we get null so we can
just check whether we have no and if I
get a null response back I'll just
return internal server error this is a
little helper method that returns one of
those action results and that represents
you know a 500 internal server error
HTTP response saying sorry
table is on
available now I've had this discussion
with people who've seen this talk before
that says internal server error is not
the appropriate thing to do with rest
here so if you think that that's the
case just imagine that there's another
response it's not really important I'm
sort of getting the the impression that
some of the criticism that has been
raised against the you know using
internal server is actually correct so
but I didn't want to change the slides
on the other hand if if we do have an ID
we just could return that ID so I just
have another helper method that returns
an action result that you know
represents 200 ok and notice that in
that case I take the ID value so the
actual integer the actual reservation ID
and I put that in the HTTP response body
so that's the contract that I have with
all of my HTTP clients I'm gonna do
quite a bit of refactoring of this sort
of behavior over and over again but I
have to preserve that overall contract
with my you know HTTP callers that if I
return 200 ok the reservation ID should
be in the response body so that's my
contract so at this point there's no a
single a wait going on but if you look
at the reservations repository here this
was developed by you know figuring out
what the try/except method needs so we
injected a repository into try/except
or the method that or the object that
try/except sits on the maitre d and then
I basically just developed if the the
algorithm already the implementation and
then I figured out what it needs in
order to do its job so this is known as
the dependency inversion principle
meaning the client gets to decide what
the API of the dependency looks like so
that's the dependency inversion
principle as one of the five you know
solid principles so so far so good and
the means it looks like this but then
you look at it and you say well but
really you know my implementation is I'm
talking to a relational database so I'd
like that to be asynchronous because
that might be more efficient in terms of
server resources I'd like to make my
implementation asynchronous and in order
to do that you have to change the types
instead of returning just normal types
you have to return tasks and we've now
introduced a leaky abstraction you know
an implementation detail is leaking into
how the app fraction is defined this is
no longer the dependency inversion
principle this is the implementation
that gets to decide what things look
like this is the definition of a leaky
abstraction and then you can say well
yeah but ok fair enough but who are we
really kidding you know we called it a
repository but everyone does understands
that it's a database so ok is it really
that important and you know I may be
able to you know I may buy that argument
and say ok fair enough its repository
represents some sort of our process
resource so it's it's I can accept that
the argument that that needs to be
asynchronous ok let's just move on and
see where this leads us ok I buy the
argument fair enough so going back to
the try accept method which is the one
that consumes that repository interface
in order to make things work now I have
to add a sink in the weight keywords
it's not a big deal with just a few
things that we have to add so that's not
so bad I also have to change the return
type to a task and this means I also now
have to change the return type of my
interface definition in a Maitre D' now
at this point these are now this annoys
me because you know I could I can buy
the argument that the repository is an
hour process resource that needs to be
asynchronous ok fine I buy that this is
a domain concept why my business
decision logic has to be asynchronous is
not clear there is nothing in the
concept of making a business decision
that says this has to happen
asynchronously but it for technical
reasons it does but you know
conceptually there's no reason for that
so I find this annoying but we can move
on and look at the post method we just
have to add a weight on that as well now
because try/except is asynchronous and
that means we also have to add you know
async and return a task so so far so
good now at this point we're basically
done because most web frameworks
nowadays understand asynchronous
programming so that's that's good so
we're done and what I've shown you here
is is basically a conclusion that other
people have reached a long time ago you
know if you want we think you need
to be easing all the way so nothing new
in this and this is not the point of the
talk is sort of like the premise and
people will tell you that that's just
the way it is there's no other way and
you know I always look up when people
say you know category little statements
like this and say okay really you know I
just have to come up with one counter
example that proves that there is
another way and then I will have
disproven that assertion there and and I
can do that now to be clear this is the
you know the end of part 1 of the talk
we've now established what's the problem
is I'm gonna put it aside a little bit
and start talking about something else
but ultimately I'm gonna show you
another way and I want to be clear that
the other way I'm gonna show you I make
no claim that that other way is better
it's just another way and personally I
feel that you know I sometimes just
using a sing in a way that like I just
shown you that's perfectly fine it's a
little bit of a compromise but it's easy
and you just have to you know sprinkle
on some async and a wait and then all
it's good in other cases I actually
believe that what I'm going to show you
next is the better option but I'm not
even you know on you know one side or
the other side of that fence it depends
you know like all good decisions so the
point of the talk is just to you know
inform you that there is an alternative
and now when you are aware that that
alternative exists you can make a proper
choice if you don't know if you only
know one way of doing things you have no
choice if you know more than one way of
doing things now you have a choice so
that's the point all right so I'm gonna
put this problem aside a little bit and
I'm gonna start looking and another
frequently asked question and that is
how do you get the value out of my
monette now I'm not going to assume that
you know what a monad is we'll get back
to that in a little while but in short
the answer to this question is mu so mu
is this character basically means
something like null void emptiness
something like that but there is a
tradition in Zen Buddhist philosophy
that interprets this this word as
meaning on ask the question and if you
want a Western perspective on this whole
send Buddhist philosophy thing they
do worse with your time than reading zen
and the art of motorcycle maintenance
but since your program as you probably
rather want to read a grade Alisha box
because that's actually written by a
computer science system but it also
talks about the same idea you know on
asking the question we we see that a lot
when people are trying to learn new
things particularly you know in
information technology and programming
there's a related problem called the XY
problem which is so common on Stack
Overflow that Stack Overflow has a FAQ
about that basically the curse when
people are trying to learn new things so
learning a new programming language
learning a new library learning a new
framework whatever it is we we see this
happening a lot and the way to explain
this is that we we could say you have
some sort of you're trying to learn
something new trying to learn a new way
of doing things and you're trying to
accomplish a goal and we'll call that
goal why and based on your knowledge
about other things that you already know
you form a plan for how you want to
accomplish your goal and that plan you
know involves a series of steps one of
the steps we can call that X you're
stuck on that step you can't figure out
figure out how to do X and you think you
know if I can just figure out how to do
X I know how to do all the other steps
and that will enable me to accomplish my
goal why so you go on Stack Overflow or
somewhere else and you say how do I do X
and then you're met with a barrage of
you know why do you want to do X that's
stupid you know quit asking stupid
questions or whatever people say on
Stack Overflow but if you M managed to
find someone who would actually
interested in engaging in a real
dialogue with you and you know together
you may be able to flush out that you're
really trying to do Y and as soon as the
expert that's trying to help you figure
this out that oh you read try to do y
okay in that case you should do that and
the set will enable you to do y you not
need the other thing makes sense you
know we're going to come from but in the
new thing you're trying to learn that's
just not a thing at all there's a
completely different way of approaching
the problem so this this happens a lot
now this happens a lot when people are
starting to look into functional
programming in statically typed
languages so we can sort of what I've
tried to do here is I sort of try to
boil down all sorts of
detail questions into this common
question you know how do I get the value
out of my monad because it sort of like
often boils down into that and the short
answer is that you don't but hmm I
haven't told you what a monad is and I'm
not assuming that you know what it is so
we'll just briefly cover that I think
you can do this in about 10 minutes
so in short monad is a functor you can
flatten and you go okay fair enough
what's a functor it's not really helpful
so we will have to start with you know
just defining what a functor
is and once you understood what that is
you know Mona it's actually pretty on
pretty easy to understand what you want
you understand what a functor is and the
fact it's not that hard to understand so
it's you know you know Mona's have been
you know made into this scary thing that
it doesn't need to be at all it's it's
pretty straightforward actually so a
functor is a data container it's not a
docker container it's not a dependency
injection container it's not a shipping
container it's just a data structure
that contains values if you will or
other data there so we can imagine that
we can draw it as some sort of rectangle
here so this would be some sort of data
type that's generically typed so it's a
container of other objects so you know
it could be foo of T and that would be a
container of things of the type T you
know generically typed and in order for
data container to be a functor it must
support something we call a structure
preserving map and that means we can
translate all the data that's inside the
container and the return value of making
such a translation is a new container
with all the contents translated so this
seems a little bit abstract so let's put
some examples in so the simplest example
of a functor is some sort of collection
so this could be a list of TI a mobile
of T you know an array whatever all of
these things together is just the list
function is that is example of one type
of functor functors are much more
abstract idea so a structure preserving
map could be something like this where
you say well let's just add one to each
of those numbers and now I have a new
collection with some other numbers but
since it is a generically type container
we don't have to stick stick to numbers
we can translate all the numbers into
strings
we could translate them all into boolean
values so this idea about this
translation being structured for serving
it's it depends a little bit about what
the container me is you know what the
function is what the structure is but
for collections here it's something as
it relates to the size of the container
so you'll notice the input container
there has the size of six elements so
all the outputs also have the size of
six elements and the order of all the
output collections here is determined by
the order of the elements in the input
collection so that's why you know
particularly on the third example there
was boolean values that's why it says
false false false true true false and
not in some other order and you could
also say well why do we need to have all
of that repetition because there's you
know only two values true and false why
don't we just collapse them well because
this is not a set operation this is just
a translation of collections and we
preserve the structure of the original
container so that what is that's what it
means to have a structure for serving
nav for collections and I'll talk about
what it means for other functions in a
moment now one thing we'll also notice
is that the output of such an operation
is itself a container and that means we
could use that as an input for another
step so we can now you know compose
things together like that and if we want
to see what that looks like in c-sharp
for example we could start by creating
an array it doesn't have to be an array
but I will tend to use a race throughout
this talk because that's just the terse
syntax and G sharp but this could also
have been a list of T or something else
so here we have an array of numbers the
structure preserving map in c-sharp is
called select most other languages call
it map but for reasons it's called
select in c-sharp so here I just take
you know for each of the element it is
to add one to those elements and the
output of that is a new type of
collection and I can do it a second step
and turn them all into strings and I
like this and now I have you know an
array of strings so if you look at
something like this you'd say well okay
so this is a functor turns out also to
be a monad and then you look at this and
you say well why why our people are
asking that question how do I get the
value of my Moana because it's pretty
clear that if you understand that this
is a monad we'll get back to what alone
in a moment it seems fairly clear that
it's not really a sensible question to
ask you know how to get the value out of
my array because okay which value the
first one the third one the last one
what are you talking about you know you
have to be more specific than that and
what do you want to do if they array is
empty you know you know that an array
might be empty so the value is
nonsensical it doesn't make any sense
you have to you know say you know which
values you want and what do you want to
do if the array is empty at least you
have to tell me those things so people
don't ask that question but on the other
hand most people don't realize that you
know using select like this that you're
actually using a list as a functor
because the Microsoft documentation
doesn't tell you that for reasons that
I've never really been able to
understand so I believe that when people
you know encounter the concept of
functions and monads for the first time
they tend to encounter it in other
contexts and often they encountered it
in the context where you know I call
them unit containers so there's a subset
of monads that have this extra quality
that they are containers of exactly one
value now unit containers just my
terminology one example might be lazy of
tea this has been around internet for a
decade or more and this is a lazy
computation it is guaranteed to contain
exactly one value of the type T it's
just lazily computed so in the dotnet in
Internet itself it's not a functor
because doesn't have select method but
we can add one we can add a select
method as an extension method that turns
a lazy of T into lazy of T result and
the implementation is basically just a
one-liner I'm not gonna dwell too much
in the implementation I'd rather you
know talk about how you can use such a
thing so what I can do here is as an
example I can create a lazy of int and
even though you'll notice that there's a
threat of sleep here that will block the
threat for 10 seconds now that lazy of
int you know all this expression it
completes immediately because it's a
lazy evaluated computation and what I
can do now is I can transform my lazy
int into a lazy of string using my new
select method and
still completes immediately if I want to
you know get the string out of why I can
force evaluation by going dot a value
and at this point it's gonna block for
ten seconds if I do it a second time
it's just gonna complete immediately
again because lacy of t remembers the
value once it's evaluated in once so
that Y variable that lacy of string
behaves exactly like you'd imagine of
how you'd expect a lazy computation to
behave and that means that select
projection there preserves the
invariance or preserves the expected
behavior of what it means to be a lazy
computation so that is a structure for
serving map so that means lazy of T is a
factor we just have to add that you know
selects extension method and that makes
it a functor not only can we do that
with lazy of T we can do that with tasks
for T as well you know as you can tell
the implementation is a little bit
different but we can walk through a very
similar example here you know creating a
task of int complete immediately even
though the task starts to run on a
background process if I want to you know
turn my task of int into a task of
string I can now do that with my new
select method and that still completes
immediately only when I await the value
you will it block for whatever time is
left from there was 10 seconds that it's
going to delay if I were a weight the
variable once more again it completes
immediately because like lazy of t task
of t also remembers the result once it's
calculated at once so again you know all
the things we'd expect from a task of
string is true even though we've made
their projection that selectmen that
preserves the invariance of what it
means to be an asynchronous task and
that means it's a structure for serving
map it preserves the structure of what
it means to be asynchronous
so that's a functor as well so not only
is lazy of t a functor task of TC
functor as well so you'll notice that
I've written you know this selects
method called using method call syntax
but I could also have written it using
query syntax like this so normally when
people see query syntax if they use it
at all they think of it as being
something related to ienumerable or
maybe i queryable in this case if X is
ienumerable of in then Y is inferred to
be ienumerable of string but now that we
have those select methods for lazy of T
that means this syntax actually also
works for lazy of T so if you have a
lazy of int you can turn that into a
lazy of string using query syntax and
the same thing is true for tasks so this
might be a little bit surprising they
said you just have to add the Select
method and then this syntax is now all
of a sudden available to you it wasn't
before but by adding the Select method
it becomes available and you could do
this with your own custom types and you
say wow what is the magic that makes
this happen well the magic that makes
this happen is because the C sharp team
designed that language feature around
the concept of a functor so basically
they said well if the type looks like a
functor because it has the appropriate
select method then this this syntax will
compile so the the C sharp understands
functors and it understands monads as
well actually so we haven't talked about
what a monad is so that's the next thing
it's a function you can flatten and then
you go say well what what does that mean
we know one-wayness a function not flat
and so I'm gonna show you a couple of
examples of that as well so we go back
to you two lists first and then we've
kind of look at tasks in in two minutes
so a string like this one here has a
split instance method so you can you say
this method to split a string on the
comma for example like this one and what
you get is an array of strings what if
you have an array of comma separated
strings like this one though now if you
go select on that one you say well I'm
gonna select each of the strings are not
going to split them in that case you
kind of get a nested array you get an
array of an array of strings and that's
not always what you want sometimes you
just want a flat list so there's another
method you can use for that you can use
select many and if you use select many
you get a flat list so why is it called
select many I believe the reason for
that I haven't haven't any authoritative
source on that but I believe that the
reason for that is that when you're
doing a select what happens inside that
lambda expression produces many values
you know split produces many values so
you're doing select and you're selecting
many values and then you're flattening
as you go so that's why it's called
select many that's my theory anyway but
you'll notice that it enables us to
flatten as we go and that capability
you know this method select many that's
what turns a function into a monad if
your father can do this also then it's a
monad that's basically what it means
there's a little bit more to it but
that's the intuition you need that's
basically all you need to know now you
understand what a monad is so what about
something I task could they be nested as
well well yeah here's a task of Ind
here's another task of IND what if I
wanted to add them together I want to
use my new select query I can try to do
that but you know the result of that Zed
turns out to be a task of a task of an
int so that's an astute task how do I
get the value out of that well you can
actually do this you know wait oh wait
Zed that's a little bit of audio I was a
little bit surprised when I discovered
that you can write stuff like that but
you can but imagine that you'd nest the
tasks even further and then you would
have to go a waiter waiter waiter waiter
waiter Zed that's that seems a little
bit clunky that's not really the nicest
way of writing code so um can we flatten
as we go yes we can we just need to add
a select many extension method to task
with T and I'm not going to show you
what it looks like you can google it
it's pretty straightforward
or it might be a good exercise but if
you add a select many extension method
you can do that and then we're
flattening as we go and then Z is just a
normal unlisted task event and once
you've added that select many methods
you can also rewrite the same query in
query syntax and now most of the async
and await keywords actually disappear
and you can just have this sort of
Cartesian you know you know combination
of things happening here so that works
as well so tasks of T is a monad just
like lay shift you can do the same thing
with a shifty that's a monad as well
right so there's definitely a subset of
monads where it makes sense to ask the
question you know how do I get the value
out of my monad because you can
and for lacy of string you just have to
go dot value and the same thing applies
to you know task of string you can await
it you see this in other languages as
well we have something very similar in F
sharp called async of string that you
can also you know get the string out of
it by running the asynchronous
computation even Haskell has quite a few
of those unit containers simplest one is
one called identity but you can get the
value out of those containers if you if
you'd like to there so this is a concept
that you know pops up in many different
languages so these are not all monads
these are just some Mona's these are the
containers that I call unit containers
because they're guaranteed to contain
exactly one value and for that subset it
makes sense to ask the question how do
you get the value out of it but where
think it really starts to break down for
people is when you run into what I call
semi containers so these are containers
of data that looked like they contain a
single value except for the cases where
it doesn't so it may or may not contain
a value and you probably know nala Belov
T this is again it's been around
internet for many many years
so with nullable of T what people are
often do what you've seen an example of
before is you have some sort of novel in
for example an ID and then you start
checking you know is it know if it's not
know I know it's safe to access ID dot
value in this case value is a customer
ID and I can create a new customer out
of the customer ID but you'll notice
that it says return here so this little
code snippet is something that sits in a
large method that returns a customer
that's basically what we can infer from
this so we if we want to return a
customer we need to also tell the
compiler okay what do we do if ID turns
out to be no there isn't an else branch
you must deal with this otherwise your
code will not compile and then people go
I don't know what to do I'll throw an
exception and if you write code like
this and you know you calculate this in
a little method you know now you have a
little method that says you know get
customer the returns a customer and the
next thing you know I come by and I say
oh there's this method that returns a
customer I'm gonna call that I'm gonna
you know interacting with the customer
that I get as a return value hey all my
code compiles that's good let's put it
in production and then once I put it in
production you know half the time it's
gonna throw that exception because I
didn't realize that that was the case so
if you're structuring the code like this
you're basically just you know putting
out a minefield where your code is just
you know waiting to explode at runtime
at various different cases so it makes
the code really hard to to maintain and
understand what's going on there so
don't do that that's that's a bad way of
structuring code but then the problem is
you know what then then what are we
supposed to do so let's look at that
okay turns out that you know functors
might actually help us so we can make na
level of T a functor with some
constraints however the constraints are
that T that's the input generic type and
T resolved that's the output generic
type must both be structs you know they
must both be value types and the reason
for that is that your novel of T itself
has that constraint on the type
definition that T must be a struct so
within that subset of all types and net
though novelty is still functor so you
can write code like this you can say
well I can translate an honorable of int
int inaudible of bool because they're
both inner value types so that works
this compiles and then you look at the
code you say oh that's nice
there's no checking for null let's know
if else branch you know all that stuff
is just hidden away inside that select
method that's really neat
so I could just you know go on and do
select select select and just stay
inside that you know inaudible little
world that's that's nice can I do
something similar with mine you know
customer ID then could I do something
like this that would be nice and
unfortunately you can't because this
doesn't compile and it doesn't compile
because T and T resolved must be a
struct and customer is not a value type
that's a reference type so therefore it
doesn't compile but then maybe you're a
little bit interested and you say well
that it'd be nice if we could could we
somehow lift that constraint from
nullable of T and saying well what if T
doesn't have to be a value type what if
it could be anything that'd be nice but
we can't change multiple of T
but we can introduce our own generically
typed data containers so let's write one
called maybe of T now some people call
this idea maybe some people call it
option it's the same idea so various
different ways you can implement this
here's the simplest one that I can
easily illustrate we have a flag called
has item and then we have the item
itself and then we have two constructor
overload the first constructor doesn't
take any inputs so it just sets that
flag to false has item is false item
itself is undefined it is uninitialized
so we don't know exactly what that is in
this case it's not safe to try to access
the item there is another constructor
overloaded receives the item as an input
argument and sets the flag to true which
basically means has item is true means
the item is now initialized it is safe
to access so this is generically typed
outer container we can make it a functor
by making sure that there's a select
method so far you've seen me do select
methods as extension methods but it can
also be an instance method so we can
just put it as an instance method on may
be of T and it basically looks like this
so you'll notice that this is an
instance method and on may be of T that
returns may be of T basalts and the way
that we implement that is basically just
looking at that flag so if has item is
true that means the item itself is
initialized and it's safe to access it
and since this is an instance of maybe
of T the type of item is T and we have
this little selector coming in through
the argument which is a function that
translates a tea into a tea result so
since we have a value of the type T we
can call that selector function and that
produces a value of the type T result
and then we can use that to populate a
new maybe of T result by calling that
constructor overload there takes you
know a T result value and we return that
else we just return an empty one so
that's pretty straightforward this
preserves the structure this is the
structure preserving map because it
takes populated may be of T V of T
values and turn them into populate or
may be of T resolve values it takes
empty may be of T values and turns them
into empty
maybe of T resolve values so it
preserves the structure of what it means
to be a maybe of T object if you will so
this is a functor as well you know maybe
of T years now a functor
and we can make it a monad by also
creating a select many method I'm not
going to spend too much time talking
about the select many method because
we're not gonna use it that much
actually we're mostly going to use the
function so before we return to the
async dependency injection example just
kind of walk show you another little
example about you know how this compose
is in a very nice way so what we can do
is we can create a little wrapper a
little helper around this idea of trying
to pass a string into an integer and you
could say well but that capability
already exists we can do you know in to
try pass but again you know with the API
that you've given by top net itself you
again run into this problem that you say
well you sort of need to branch and you
say well okay if you find an integer
that's fine but what do you do in the
else branch and in this case it's clear
because we can return them populated
maybe event if we can pass the integer
and we just return an empty one if we
can't so instead of having to rely on
you know throwing exceptions or
returning no less or something else this
is always safe
whatever whatever happens here what you
get that you actually get a real object
bag you never get a non reference
exception or anything from using you
know an API like this and it composes so
we can do the same thing by trying to
pass a date-time for example and it's
entirely the same you know template that
we sort of apply to this sort of
implementation and I'll show you how
this composes so imagine that you have
to write an application that services
you know some sort of car rental
organization so you start by asking the
user you have a little method called
collect date and when you call collect
aid it
you know poses the question to the user
please enter the date from which you
would like to rent the car and the user
types and the date and that's a string
and then you call try past date with
that string and you get a maybe of date
time and then you ask another question
you call collect number of days and it
says to the user please the enter the
number of days you'd like to rent the
car
and the user enters a number and that's
a string and then you pass that string
to try pass int and you get in a maybe
of impac and you've probably asked a lot
of other questions and you sort of
gather a lot of information that way and
now you want to compose all of that you
know information into a contract because
you have a contract object that can
calculate prices and so on so you start
by you know you could we can use query
syntax for this it was greater maybe of
contract and we'll start by saying from
D and MD so that D is a date/time value
if it exists if this code runs at all
that will be a date time and value from
I and M I that I will be an integer and
we can keep on going like that so if all
those maybes are populated our maybe of
contract will also be populated it's
just one of them are you know empty then
that may be of contract will also be
empty so this is a pretty easy and
standardized way of doing data
validation there's a little bit more of
a sophisticated way of doing that but
this this it gets things done in a pinch
so so far so good well then what often
happens is people say well okay but I
have this contract and the contract has
some methods where I can call to
calculate the price and I want to show a
quote to my user my potential customers
so that they may decide to rent my car I
need to get you know I need to get the
contract out of there maybe how to do
that and people try to do something like
this but they say okay if MC has item
I'll try to access the item and then the
item is a contract and then they can
call calculate price yeah but that does
not compile because I've very
deliberately designed my maybe API so
that that doesn't work because you're
not supposed to do this again this sort
of this style of programming is brittle
because what happens if has item is
false then what's going to be the value
of Q is it going to be zero do you want
to run the risk of actually showing the
customer zero price on on the
application they're interacting with oh
you know there could be all sorts of
other issues that not you know result
from this style of programming so you're
not supposed to do that and that's why I
designed the maybe API so that this is
not possible
you know these has item and item exist
but they're you know private class field
so you can't access them from the
outside and that is by design so um if
you're not supposed to do that then what
are you supposed to do
well we already seen that you know maybe
of T is a functor so you can just do a
structure preserving map you just say
well let's just you know translate maybe
of contract it or maybe addressable by
calling calculate price inside of it now
this is a completely safe because if
there may be of contract is populated
that then lambda expression is going to
run and you cannot get a populated maybe
of decimal and if they may be of
contract is empty nothing's gonna happen
it's just gonna have a maybe of decimal
that's empty it's not gonna throw
exceptions and you also notice that
there's less code to write it means also
there's less code to understand
so this basically generalizes and this
is the general idea you know when
working with Mona's you know how do I
get the value out of my Mona well you
don't you inject the desired behavior
into the Monad which is exactly what
happened here you know I took you know
that calculate price and I just kept it
inside the Select inside them there may
be environment if you will so I'm just
going from one maybe value to another
one and that's how Co and that's the how
you're supposed to work with functional
nets and and I know what you're thinking
or maybe maybe you're thinking this yeah
but ultimately I need to produce a
results because I need to put something
on the screen so that the user can make
a decision sure fair enough
let's go back to collections for a
moment now here again we have
collections of numbers and you could say
if you don't want to put all the numbers
on the screen if you just want to put a
single number of this on the screen of
the user how would you do that well that
probably depends on how you want to
produce that single number but maybe you
just want to you know produce the sum
and you can put you know this particular
number on the screen but but sum is a
very specialized way of producing many
numbers into one maybe you want to build
you know produce the product instead and
there's no specialized product extension
method but there's a general purpose
method called aggregate that you can use
so the aggregate methods what that wants
you to do is you have to supply a little
function a little lambda expression
that says well given two values in this
case two integers please reduce it to
one and I so that's that little lambda
expression that says X comma Y and in
this case I'm just saying well I'm just
gonna multiply them together so that
takes two integers and turns them into
one integer and this just happens you
know then it takes that one integer that
you just produced and then it take gives
you the next one and so it's just you
know piecemeal reduces all the numbers
into one one number but you'll notice
that I'm using the overload here that
takes the seed and the seed is one and
the reason for that is it's not
necessarily here necessary here but if
you have an empty collection an empty
array aggregate wants to return an
integer or whatever you want to return
whatever time you want to return but you
can't return an integer from an empty
array unless you tell it you know what's
the default values in this case I'm just
using one because one time something is
just the other number so this idea of
taking a seed and a little lambda
expression that we can sort of use used
to do projections we can apply that to
maybe of tea as well now this one by the
way it returns zero because one of the
numbers is zero so that's not so
interesting but let's take that add en
apply it to maybe of tea so we'll create
another instance method on maybe of tea
I'm not going to call it aggregate I'm
going to call it match for reasons that
will become clear in a few minutes but
this is the idea is that this is again
an instance method on maybe of tea and
we will project as we go along so we
don't have to return a value of this of
the same type T we can't project it to
tea resolve as we go along but tea
results could be the same as tea eaters
no nothing prevents that so how do we
implement that again this is basically
just a one-liner you just look at the
flag has item and if that's true you
know that the item is available that
it's been initialized and it is a value
of the type T and we have this little
function sitting up there and the
argument is called just so if you're
wondering about you know nothing and
just why they're called that it's sort
of by convention that's what you
normally call things in with maybes it's
a little bit of an odd naming but just
as a function that takes a T value and
returns the tea results so you can just
call justify 'tom and return that and if
has item is false
we fall on the other side of that
ternary operator and then we can just
return the nothing value which is also
of the type T result so again this is
one of those methods where if you supply
all the appropriate arguments there it
is completely safe to call this method
it's never gonna throw exceptions unless
you know they're null and then you will
get those argument null exceptions but
apart from that you know it's always
gonna work and it's very very simple to
call and you will know exactly what to
do when you see the type signature so
now we can return to this question of
how do I combine dependency injection
with a sink and a weight without leaky
abstractions so this is part three of
the talk now we have learned enough to
see if we can address this question as
well so we we left it off by this
assertion that you know when you're
doing asynchronous programming it has to
be a single way and then I said well
yeah maybe not okay let's see if there's
another way of doing things well we need
to change things around a little bit so
the first thing I want to do is to move
the IMP you operations to the boundary
of the system this is a common trick
that you laughs this is sort of like you
know we often hear you know functional
programmers having catchphrases and and
one catchphrase is you know make illegal
states unrepresentable you'll hear
people say that all the time and you
also hear people say this a lot you know
movie and pure operations to the
boundary of the system turns out to be a
good idea in object-oriented programming
as well basically the idea is that you
know whatever interacts with the real
world you know whatever queries your
database whatever sends off emails
whatever you know paints things on the
screen that's the operation that
interacts with the real world that
should have happen at the edge of the
system and you know we have an object
oriented architecture description called
ports and adapters that talks it about
exactly that style of architecture so
this is a tried and true approach to
object oriented architecture as well so
and what's an impure operation I think
it's easiest just to explain that by
some examples because we have examples
of two types of of impure operations
here and that there are only two types
so we have examples of both so read read
reservations he has impure because it's
non-deterministic in order for a
function to be pure that a function must
be deterministic and that means
if you call the function with the same
input documents it should always produce
the same output value but when you do
that with a database interaction you
know you can call it outta base with you
know a particular set of input arguments
and you could get one result and then
you could do it you know five or ten
minutes later and now you get a another
set of results because the state of the
database changed in the meantime we
don't consider the state of the database
to be part of the function so you know
from the perspective of our code such an
operation looks non-deterministic so
that means it's not pure and another
source of impurity is repository to
create and that's because it has a side
effect this would create a row in the
database every time we call it and pure
functions are deterministic have no side
effects so if one of those two things
are not true that means the operation is
impure so these two operations are
impure for each their own reasons so we
want to move those to the boundary of
the system I don't want to get rid of
them because these are absolutely
necessary things in order to get to make
the entire application do what it's
supposed to do but they shouldn't happen
here they should happen closer to the
boundary of the system at the edge of
the system so how to do that well the
first one is the easiest one so we're
gonna start with this one you'll notice
that repository that read reservations
this always happens this method call is
always you know happening as the first
thing unconditionally so you could say
well okay so why is it the
responsibility of this try accept method
to make that method call could me just
say well the responsibility of this
method is actually just to make a
business decision why does it need to go
and and pretend that it's doing you know
interacting with the database couldn't
we just make the data itself the
reservations a prerequisite for you know
making that business decision and then
someone else might have the
responsibility of actually figuring out
where that are to come from because then
we can also decoupled our selves
completely from you know how to produce
that data okay so we can do that we and
the only thing we need to do is to you
know promote reservations to be a method
argument so that's pretty
straightforward but sometimes you know
things have to get worse before they get
better and why
things that will get worse now is that
it if we look at maitre d that interface
from before in order for things to still
compile we need to change the interface
definition to also take reservations as
one of the method arguments because
otherwise we can't implement that
interface and then if you say well
that's a leaky abstraction if I've ever
seen one I would agree it is this is a
leaky abstraction now this is only the
first in a series of refactorings that
I'm going to do and trust me when I'm
done with all my refactorings this is
not this is no longer gonna be a problem
so just let's just move on and you'll
see towards the end why this is not a
problem so we'll have to change the post
method a little bit as well and you
notice we already injected Maitre D' we
can just inject repository as well and
that means we can start by calling
repository to read reservations and then
now we have the reservations we can call
maitre d to try except with those
reservations and the rest of the code is
the same as before before we move on I
just want to remind you that the last
part of the code here it does exactly
what I've talked about that we you
shouldn't do you know it gets the value
out of the moment you're checking
whether the ID is null and if it's not
null you go ID dot value and it's
possible to do this with inaudible of T
but when we change things around it will
no longer be possible you're not and
we're not really supposed to do this is
this fairly simple code but it can you
know if it gets a little bit more
complicated this sort of programming
style starts to get you know brittle so
we should avoid writing code like this
so how do we get rid of or not get rid
of how do we move repository create to
the post method as well now this one is
a little bit harder because this doesn't
happen unconditionally there is a
branching instruction sitting a little
bit above where you know if we decide
that the capacity the remaining capacity
is too little we return null instead and
that means we don't call the repository
dot create so we need to figure out if
we want to move repository create to the
boundary of the system we need to
communicate to the caller the decision
we made so that they can you know decide
whether or not to
all repositories are created so how do
we communicate the decision to the
Kohler
well we are already doing that because
we're returning a novel end and we you
know I said the contract here is that if
that is null that means we didn't accept
the reservation if it's an integer you
have a reservation but the integer that
is being returned here comes from
repository to create and if I move
repository to create I will no longer
have an integer so I'm gonna need to
replace that integer with something else
and that's something else may not
actually be a value type so in general
we again we have this constraint of
multiple of T that it needs to be a
value type or a struct and if I want to
replace that integer with something else
that may not be a struct I can't do that
with no level of T but I can do it with
maybe of T so just as an initial step
I'm going to change my novel of int into
a maybe of int and that's a fairly
straightforward thing so just if you pay
attention to the top line I'm just going
to return replace that novel of int with
a maybe event and then it causes me to
do a few changes in the code instead of
returning null I'm now returning an
empty maybe event instead of just you
know taking an int and relying on an
implicit conversion from into novel of
int and now return a populated maybe
event that contains the ID I will move
forward from this but again we have to
change the Maitre D' interface
definition now we have a maybe of int as
the return value from calling maybe to
try majorly to try accept so how do we
turn that into an I action result how do
we turn that into an HTTP response now
before we were doing null checking and
then we were taking pulling the value
out of the monad or the novel of T we
can't do that anymore because that's
what I showed you just before you can't
check whether or not the maybe is
populated you because you're not
supposed to do that so what can we do
instead well we can use that match
method you know that's that that was
like the same thing as the aggregate
method and you'll notice that I've just
immediately go return m dot match so
whatever match returns that's what I'm
gonna return so that must be an I action
result you know one of those HTTP
responses
I'm gonna supply some arguments to the
match method I'm gonna use named
arguments so that we can see what which
is which so in the nothing case I'm
gonna return internal server error
that's an I action result and that
basically means you know if we match on
nothing and then we still return 500
internal server error if we match on
just I have to supply a function so I
write this the lambda expression here
that receives the the ID the integer and
just call 200 with that ID so 200 okay
responds still contains the reservation
ID in the response body just like you
know is just like we did before that's
the contract I have with my HTTP clients
so this is also the explanation of of
you know why did I call that method
match because using name documents like
this this starts to look like pattern
matching if you ever seen pattern
matching in F sharp for example this
looks like the same idea you match on
nothing and that is one thing you match
and just that's another thing okay so
now we're in the position where we can
move repository create to the boundary
of the system now if I take away that
method call here I no longer have an int
to return so I'm gonna return a maybe a
reservation instead so an empty one to
indicate that we didn't accept the
reservation and just a populated maybe a
reservation with the original
reservation inside to indicate that this
is the reservation we accepted and again
we have to change the major' the
interface but we'll just move on and
pretend that that's not an issue because
that's not so now I have a maitreya
reservation when I've called Maitre D'
to try except I'm gonna need a and an
integer because I need to put that
integer in a 200 ok response so it'd be
nice if I had a maybe of int that's what
I have before how do I turn a maybe a
reservation into a maybe event well
maybe it's a functor so I can just do
select so I can just do this so I can
call repository create here and that's
you know again this is going to run if
the maybe of reservation is populated
and if the maybe of reservation is not
populated this is just not gonna run I'm
just gonna get you know an empty maybe
back so now I have a maybe event well
not quite
I have a maybe of a task of an inn
because that reservations create you
know method call here it's absolutely
asynchronous so we actually have a stack
of Mona's here but it turns out not to
be an issue so we can just move on so we
still have maybe on the outside and that
means I can still call the match method
now the match method Leah has become a
little bit more awkward to use because I
need to return tasks from it within that
match method so you notice it says tasks
from resolves and so on so it looks not
it's not quite as pretty as before but
we'll deal with that so it'll be pretty
again in a few minutes so let's not
worry about that so at this point
something interesting happens if you try
to compile there will be a compiler
warning that the compiler will tell you
this async method lacks await operators
and you go and say yeah it says async
but there's no await anywhere so why
does it need to be a thing again it
doesn't just let's get rid of that this
is this was well this is what was
bothering me all along and now I've
solved the problem you know my business
logic does not have to be asynchronous
why should it have to be asynchronous
it's no longer a synchronous problem
solved I have to change them a to the
interface the only change I need to make
in the post method is that you know that
a weight keyword that since in front of
try except that have to go away but
apart from that that's the only change I
need to make but if I go back and look
at the maitre d and the try accept
method again there's another thing that
we may notice and that is that
repository dependency is also no longer
being used so we can get rid of that as
well so what we are left with now is
pretty close to something we would call
a pure function it's not entirely pure
because there's a little is a little bit
of state mutation going on there towards
the end but that would actually be
fairly easy to to also deal with that
problem if you think that's a problem
but it's pure enough in the sense that
it's it's deterministic what happens
inside the try accept method the only
thing that influences which path you end
up taking through that you know method
is just the input arguments and the
capacity which is just is just an input
to the constructor so we can completely
control which path is being taken by the
try accept method and
returns by making sure that we supplied
with the right arguments so why are we
having that Maitre D' dependency and
some people might say yeah but this is
because it makes the code testable
because now I can create a stub of my
Maitre D' dependency and I can use a
mocking framework to set up some
expectations that you know makes you
know that completely controls how
try/except behaves but then I say well
yeah if you use the Maitre D' object you
can completely control hi try except
behaves because you just have to make
sure that it receives the right input
arguments so we'll just do this we'll
just create the concrete class and get
rid of that dependency so that means
that interface you no longer have that
dependency and if you consistently
remove that dependency from all occurred
the the interface is no longer required
you can just delete the interface and
move on we still have the capability we
still have the Maitre D' object but now
just no longer implements the interface
and that again makes the code simpler
and maybe you think it's not so pretty
to have that new Maitre D' sitting in
line there so why do we need to create a
new one of those every time we need it
so we could just promote that to a
little class field and you know do some
other refactoring and then the code
might look up looking like this which is
much prettier so at this point you'll
notice that we start by simply just
returning a weight and then there's sort
of a pipeline of operations that happens
we just kick it off by repository that
read reservations and then you notice
that we go select select many and and so
on so since there's this select many
method call there there must be a Mon
art monad in in in in effect there and
the monette that we are using here is
the async monad or the task of T monad
so and this is because you know
repository a tree preservation returns a
task so that's an asynchronous operation
querying the database is saying
synchronous as it's supposed to be and
towards the the end the penultimate line
there inside that Traverse and let's not
worry about what that is the it says
repository create that's still an
asynchronous operation just as it's
supposed to be because we're writing to
the database and all of this happens
asynchronously because you'll notice the
post method is still asynchronous it's
returned it returns a task of I action
results so all the thing
mr. need to be asynchronous are still
asynchronous sir in this way in this
sense you're still acing all the way but
the decision the business decision
I just inject that into the e
synchronous context and that is not a
synchronous because it doesn't have to
be so how do I combine dependency
injection with acing in a weight without
leaky abstractions well you inject the
desired behavior into the async monad
which is exactly what I did i injected
that in a synchronous decision logic
into the overall asynchronous context
and everyone is happy it's a win-win and
we should have known this already 20
minutes ago because we know that you
know how do you get the value out of my
moment well you don't you inject the
desired behavior into the moment so
behavior injection not dependency
injection so and if you're interested in
learning more about this in on my block
there's an article called asynchronous
injection which basically walks you
through all the code that I've shown
here and there's a link to github
repository where you can look at all the
code and I'm out of time
so I'm not going to take questions but
I'll be around at the conference and
I'll be happy to talk to you so you can
just come and ask me questions when you
see me and we can figure out anything
you may have of questions in that way so
thank you all for coming and enjoy the
rest of the conference